conforme avanzamos en nuestro curso de
estadística es valioso suponer que
ciertas estadísticas tienen
distribuciones normales o distribuciones
binomial es ya que si lo hacemos también
podemos hacer suposiciones interesantes
porque podemos pensar en las
distribuciones normales o binomial es
como la suma de muchas ejecuciones
independientes así que suponemos que las
ejecuciones son independientes existen
muchas situaciones en las que esto es
razonable sin embargo hay ocasiones en
las que no lo es tanto por ejemplo
imaginemos que estamos aplicando una
encuesta a las personas que salen de un
centro comercial sin embargo como estas
personas están saliendo del centro
comercial no podemos pedirles que
después de contestar la encuesta vuelvan
a entrar para poder tener reemplazo y
que cada ejecución sea realmente
independiente pero intuitivamente
sabemos que si hay 10.000 personas en el
centro comercial y vamos a muestrear a
10 de ellos es tan importante que las
muestras sean realmente independientes o
podemos usarlas aún cuando se acerquen a
ser independientes con base en esta idea
de querer hacer inferencia
sobre cosas que son cercanas a tener una
distribución normal o binomial tenemos
lo que llamamos la regla del 10% la
regla del 10% nos dice que si tenemos
una muestra de tamaño menor o igual al
10% de la población está bien suponer
que hay una independencia aproximada hay
varias formas sofisticadas de llegar a
este umbral del 10% quizá podríamos
tomar el 9% o el 1% de la población pero
el 10% es un número entero muy sencillo
de usar y si vemos algunos ejemplos
tangibles veremos que es una muy buena
aproximación por ejemplo digamos que sea
x el número de niños seleccionados en un
salón con n estudiantes en tres
ejecuciones donde el 50% de la clase son
niños y el 50% son niñas
aquí tenemos varios valores para n 20
estudiantes en la clase 30 estudiantes
en la clase 100 estudiantes en la clase
y 10.000 estudiantes en la clase en esta
columna tenemos la probabilidad de
seleccionar 3 alumnos con reemplazo para
cada uno de estos escenarios y en
otra columna tenemos la probabilidad de
seleccionar tres alumnos sin reemplazo
en la última columna tenemos la
proporción de tres con respecto a toda
la población y así podemos ver si la
regla del 10% es efectiva en la primera
columna en donde seleccionamos tres
alumnos con reemplazo y como es con
reemplazo cada ejecución es
verdaderamente independiente y si las
ejecuciones son independientes entonces
x es verdaderamente una variable
binomial en la segunda columna las
ejecuciones son sin reemplazo de modo
que no son verdaderamente independientes
por lo tanto oficialmente en esta
columna la variable x no se considera
verdaderamente binomial veamos si hay un
umbral en el que el tamaño de la muestra
sea un porcentaje de la muestra lo
suficientemente pequeño como para que
podamos decir que x es casi binomial en
todos los casos donde tenemos
ejecuciones independientes y el 50% de
la población son niños y el 50% son
niñas siempre tendremos un medio por un
medio por un medio lo que en todos los
casos nos da una
habilidad de 12.5 por ciento de que x
sea igual a 3 en este caso x es una
variable binomial veamos en la segunda
columna el caso donde n es un porcentaje
grande de la población en este caso es
el 15% el porcentaje de la probabilidad
de seleccionar tres alumnos sin
reemplazo es 10.5 por ciento que es
bastante diferente del 12.5 por ciento
que obtuvimos aquí hay una diferencia de
2% pero es un 2% en relación con un 12%
por lo que hay una diferencia del 10 al
20 por ciento en términos de la
probabilidad así que aquí tenemos una
diferencia relativamente grande pero
conforme aumenta el tamaño de la
población sin incrementar el tamaño de
la muestra vemos que estos números se
van acercando cada vez más de manera que
cuando tenemos una población de 10.000 y
realizamos tres ejecuciones los números
se acercan mucho este porcentaje era de
12.49 por ciento más o menos pero si lo
redondeamos a la décima más cercana
vemos que se acercan bastante por lo
tanto podemos decir que
si la muestra es 310 milésimas de la
población podemos confiar en tratar esta
columna sin reemplazo como si fuera muy
cercana a una variable binomial en el
primer escenario donde tenemos una
muestra que es el 15% de la población no
tendríamos la confianza de tratar a esta
columna sin reemplazo como si fuera una
variable aleatoria binomial pero en
dónde está el límite pues como vimos al
inicio del vídeo el límite se encuentra
en el 10% de la población si el tamaño
de la muestra es igual o menor al 10%
del tamaño de la población es razonable
tratar la variable aleatoria aunque no
sea oficialmente binomial como si lo
fuera la podemos tratar funcionalmente
como una variable binomial y a partir de
esto hacer todas las inferencias que
tendemos a hacer con respecto a este
tipo de variables dicho esto mientras
menor sea el porcentaje de la muestra
con respecto a la población es mejor
pero con esto no quiero decir que las
muestras más pequeñas son mejores que
las muestras grandes en estadística las
muestras más grandes tienden a ser
mejores que las muestras más pequeñas
pero si queremos hacer esta suposición
independencia aunque no sea por completo
verdadera queremos que la muestra sea un
porcentaje pequeño de la población en
este caso lo ideal sería que si vamos a
entrevistar a 100 personas saliendo del
centro comercial sería bueno a
asegurarnos que haya aproximadamente
1000 personas en el centro comercial
para poder considerar nuestras
ejecuciones razonablemente
independientes si hay 10.000 o 15.000
personas en el centro comercial por lo
que tendría que ser un centro comercial
bastante grande sería ideal nos vemos en
otro vídeo